- ♪ I know self-defense ♪
- ♪ I dare you to try it ♪
- ♪ I don't wanna fight ♪
- ♪ Bitch you are mine tonight ♪
(classical music)
(whack)
(classical music continues)
(repeated whacking)
(whack)
- Argh, argh, ahh!
(Classical music fades)
(Television static)
- Well, we were behind
each other in line
at the grocery store and
it was silly,
but I dropped a can of
peas and he bent over
to pick them up for me and
that's where it started.
- What can I say?
It was love at first sight
and we've been
together ever since.
- Well...
- Yes, she always has had
her own way of doing things.
(parents sigh together)
- Okay.
I see what's going on here.
- Honey.
- You don't approve
of our engagement.
- No, they're not like that.
- I'm sorry, sweetheart.
Yes, they are like that.
Look at their faces.
There's no point in trying
to reason with folks
who can't appreciate the
differences in others.
You should be ashamed
of yourselves.
(orchestral melancholy music)
- Honey, wait!
- I cannot believe that
you would bring a colored
man into our house.
(slow melancholy music)
(Mother cries)
- He's gone now.
(orchestral music begins)
- ♪ Would you look at the time ♪
- ♪ You should just
stay here tonight ♪
- ♪ I've had too much wine ♪
- ♪ You can leave
at first light ♪
- ♪ It isn't that far ♪
- ♪ Baby just stay
where you are ♪
- ♪ Back to my place ♪
- ♪ You can't escape
from my embrace ♪
- ♪ I really had
a very nice time ♪
- ♪ Let me just
refill that wine ♪
- ♪ But I really need
to just say goodbye ♪
- ♪ I would love
to see you try ♪
- ♪ Please unlock this door ♪
- ♪ It's locked
from the outside ♪
- ♪ I cannot stay tonight ♪
- ♪ Babe you're mine tonight ♪
- ♪ Look, I really have to go ♪
- ♪ You really have to stay ♪
- ♪ Hey! No means no ♪
- ♪ That is what they all say ♪
- ♪ You're hurting my arm ♪
- ♪ I won't cause you any harm ♪
- ♪ Let go of me ♪
- ♪ We can make this
harder, just easy ♪
- ♪ A woman always
comes prepared ♪
- ♪ Oh, I'm really scared ♪
- ♪ I said, this is
not what I want ♪
- ♪ Why you have
to be such a-- ♪
- ♪ I know self defense ♪
- ♪ I dare you to try it ♪
- ♪ I don't wanna fight ♪
- ♪ Bitch, you
are mine tonight ♪
(classical music continues)
(whack)
(repeated whacking)
- Ah, ah, ahhhh!
- ♪ Please
just--please go away ♪
- ♪ I thought you
wanted me to stay? ♪
- Well, well I just
changed my mind.
- ♪ I think I'll just
stay and unwind ♪
- How did this all switch?!
- ♪ Now you are my bitch ♪
- Please just be kind tonight!
- ♪ Now you're mine tonight ♪
- [Bar Patron] What's
good for you, boy,
you'll keep your
hands off my woman.
- [Bar Patron 2] Your
woman? I saw her first.
(Both patrons speaking
angrily at the same time)
(Crowd cheering)
- (Emcee) And now,
for the scat style of
Rex "The Bone Daddy" Ross
and Teddy "12 Tones" Moose.
(crowd continues cheering)
(scatting harmoniously)
- ♪ But, but, but, but,
but, but, but, but ♪
your breath smells like a butt ♪
(continues scatting)
♪ Your whole mouth smells like ♪
as old as butt poo-poo ♪
- (scats)
♪ Fee, fi, foe, fum,
what do I smell ♪
but some fat next to me ♪
(scatting continues)
- (high-pitched scatting)
♪ Baby penis. ♪
- ♪ Feel free to suck it, and
suck it, and suck it, and ♪
suck it, and suck it, and
suck it, and suck it and
feel free to suck it ♪
Feel free to suck it,
feel free to suck it
You can suck it and
put it in your mouth ♪
- (scats)
♪ Your face, your face, your
face, looks like a ball sack ♪
A wrinkle-dinkle-doo, stinky-doo
a wrinkle-dinky-deedee
ball sack ♪
- (scats)
♪ You're a taint, you're
a taint, you're a taint ♪
The space between
the butt and balls
Taint-face, taint, taint,
your face is a taint
Taint, taint, taint ♪
- ♪ Take it back ♪
- ♪ No, I won't ♪
- ♪ I never will ♪
- ♪ Take it back ♪
- ♪ No, I won't ♪
(together) ♪ Because you're a
son of a, son of a, son of a
Son of a bitch, bitch, bitch
Son of a, son of a, son of a
Son of a bitch, bitch, bitch ♪
(crowd cheers)
- ♪ You don't need
to fight over me ♪
There's plenty
of that
vag-ay-vag-ay-vag-ay-gina
Vagina
There's plenty of ♪
You know what I'm
talking about, right?
Y'all know what
I'm talkin' about.
(crowd cheers)
(graphic swooshes)
- [MLK Jr.] Free at last!
Free at last!
Thank God, Almighty.
We are free at last.
(crowd cheers)
- [Announcer] Ladies
and gentlemen,
please welcome your next
speaker, Reverend Robert Jones.
(crowd continues cheering)
- How am I supposed
to follow that?
I can't--nobody can follow that!
How's...
Oh.
Alright.
Good afternoon, um...
That is the best speech I have
ever heard in my entire life!
Ever.
I have never heard
a better speech.
And now it is my turn to speak.
Huh...(laughs nervously)
Who put this running
order together, right?
You know, Dr. King, uh--
(laughs nervously)
He actually covered a lot, a
lot of what I was gon' say.
Um, you know my speech is...
You're gonna find
this funny, y'all.
My speech is actually called
"A Vision for the Future".
I'm not sayin' Dr. King
copied my speech, I'm--
(crowd boos)
No! No, I'm--I'm not--I'm
sayin' I'm not sayin' that.
I'm not saying he
tried to copy it.
Why don't y'all
listen to what I'm s--
(crowd continues to boo)
Wow! You know what?
No, come on.
I'm just sayin'!
I'm just sayin'.
I'm sayin' it as a joke!
Did I not say it like a joke?
(various dissenting
noises from crowd)
Nope.
Apparently, I have
six more minutes.
See, red, red hills
of Georgia...got that
out there....fuck.
Okay! You know what?
Alright, here--here's
somethin'--here's somethin' new.
Here's somethin' brand new.
How about--okay, this
is off me talkin' off
the top of my head
here everybody,
Wh-wh-why--how about if we let
black people enslave
white people for--
(crowd begins booing)
Okay, you know that sounded
a lot better in my head.
That wouldn't work.
Is it warm? Is
anybody else warm?
Whew!
Okay, okay, okay here's
what we're gonna do,
here's what we're gonna do.
Alright, Dr. King talkin'
about all the races
comin' together, right, right?
So what I want every negro
to do here today is find
the nearest white person
and give them a hug.
Just--just give 'em a hug, okay?
No, sir!
You're not being attacked.
You're being hugged, okay?
Everybody take it easy, okay?
Everybody relax.
You know, what?
You don't need 10 negroes
huggin' one white person, okay?
Let's just-- Let's--
that's the new rule.
Not 10-on-1. 1-on-1.
So just take turns
and everything, okay?
So everybody relax, okay?
Oh my goodness.
Sir? She doesn't
need to be defended!
She doesn't need to be defended!
She's okay! She's okay, okay?
Alright, sir--ma'am--okay,
Officer, is that necessary?
I don't think that was
necessary, Officer.
Hey, hey! Please!
Please take it easy, sir!
Everybody take it easy, alright?
These are just hugs. You
are not being attacked!
(water hose spraying)
Ahh, what are you doing?
(crowd continues to boo)
(graphic swooshes)
- Spare some change?
- Sorry, man, I
ain't got nothin'.
- Alright.
(car engine roars)
(police siren chirps)
(melancholy music continues)
- Hold it right there.
Let's see some ID.
- What? I didn't even
do anything, man.
- Are you talking back to me?
- No, I was just walkin', man.
- Look! There is no reason
for you to get upset, sir.
- I'm not. I'm not.
- Alright, that's it! Put
your hands on your head.
- Put my hands up?
- Put your hands
on your head! Yes!
(suspenseful music)
- [Officer] You had your chance.
(handcuffs clink together)
(Siren wails)
- Listen, man, can I just
ask you, like, politely,
what it is that I did?
- Think I was born yesterday?
- Come on, man, I was--
- Get in the car.
Duck your head.
- Ow!
(grunts in pain)
- Alright, Officer,
I'll take it from here.
(suspenseful music fades)
- Well. Hi, Wally!
Good to see ya.
(handcuffs clink together)
He's all yours!
- Alright!
- What?
(Wally chuckles)
- Y'all have a good night!
- Alright!
- Thanks, man, but
where are we goin'?
- I'm glad you asked.
(synth-like, otherworldly
noises emit from open door)
Follow me!
- Through there?
(whirring wind)
(futuristic synth sounds)
(Wally laughs)
- Whoa! Look at this place.
Where are we?
- Just be patient
and I'll show ya.
- What? Your suit changed!
(upbeat music begins)
- ♪ Follow me to
a place I know ♪
Where there ain't no
place and no sorrow
It's a place to be
if your skin is brown
I'm talkin' bout Negrotown ♪
- Negrotown?
What, like, Atlanta?
(Wally laughs)
- Almost. Now, be
quiet while I sing.
♪ Negrotown, you can
walk the street ♪
Without gettin' stopped,
harassed, or beat
There's always a cab when
you need to get around ♪
- And they always stop!
♪ In Negrotown ♪
- I think I'm getting it.
It's like a utopia
for black people!
- Yeah! But seriously.
Shut the (beep) up.
♪ Won't get followed
while you try to shop ♪
- ♪ You can wear your
hoodie and not get shot ♪
- ♪ No white folks to
cross the street in fear ♪
- ♪ No trigger happy
cops or scared cashiers ♪
- [Wally] ♪ That loan
application can't
get turned down ♪
- [Banker] ♪ You're always
approved in Negrotown ♪
- This is amazing!
- I know, right?
- [Dancers] ♪ We're
going down to Negrotown ♪
Where the strong black
men are raining down
There's light-skin,
dark-skin, every shade
And there's no white
bitches to take them away ♪
- This sounds too
good to be true!
- It does, doesn't it?
But can I (bleep)
finish the song?
- I mean, can a (bleep) finish?
- I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
- ♪ In Negrotown, you'll
live long and well ♪
There's no disease,
no sickle cell
No stupid ass white
folks touching your hair
Or stealin' your coats
or gleaming in stairs.
Hanging out in a group
doesn't make you a gang
Every word that you say
ain't considered slang.
No one trying to get
in on the latest trend,
By making you their
token black friend.
It's a place where
all Madea's found ♪
- ♪ It's a (bleep)
black playground ♪
- ♪ Talkin' bout Negrotown ♪
- ♪ Talkin' bout Negrotown! ♪
(distant voices)
- Sir?
Sir?
Sir.
Alright, get up.
Let's go, get up.
- Wait, wait, wait,
hold on, wait.
I thought I was
goin' to Negrotown?
- Oh, you are.
(upbeat piano music)
(car engine starts)
(upbeat scat music)